Hello everyone.
Welcome back to Google Live.
I'm Claudio and I'm one of the
engineers in the Google Drive
Developer Relations team.
And today I'm very excited to
talk about the Google Drive
Realtime API.
We announced this API on
Tuesday, so a few days ago.
And we already covered it on our
previous GDL, with Steve
[? Basil ?], My colleague,
talking about what you can do
with the Google Drive
Realtime API.
We're going to have more
sessions about these exciting
new features.
But today what I'm going to show
you is how to build your
first application that uses
the Drive Realtime API.
I will basically follow the
instructions in the Quick
Start Guide in the
documentation.
So this can be used in addition
to the documentation
if you think that anything
is not clear.
I hope I will make it better
and clear now.
So if we want to start
using the Google
Drive Realtime API--
which let me just remind you
that this will let you have
collaboration features in your
application as we do in our
web editors.
So if you go to Google Docs
and edit a document and
someone else edits the same
document, you will see the
changes from the other
guy and he will see
yours in real time.
This is what you can
now add to your
application using this API.
So if you want to start using
the Google Drive Realtime API
the documentation, with the
samples, and the reference
guide, and everything
you need--
and this video is going
to be there as well--
is at developers.googl
e.com/drive/realtime, which is
the page that I have open
in front of me.
So if you can look at my screen,
this is the landing
page for the Realtime API.
And it's pretty simple.
There are just a few links here,
so it should be easy to
know where to go.
What I'm going to do now is to
try the Realtime Quick Start.
Of course with the Quick Start
it will build your first
[INAUDIBLE], this will
be very quick.
But then to make it a proper app
with a lot of features you
will have to go back to the
Developer's Guide, and maybe
use the other tools we have,
such as the Realtime API
Playground, and test all the
other features we have.
So if you click on the Realtime
Quick Start link,
this will take you to another
page which is a
step-by-step guide.
There's actually three steps,
configuration, writing the
code, and running the sample.
So not much is needed.
This is probably one of the
fastest Quick Starts we have.
And at the end of this we will
have a simple web application
written in JavaScript
with two text boxes.
And these two textbooks will
be synchronized with the
Realtime API.
So whenever you change the
content of one you will see
the same changes reflected
in the second one.
If we follow this Quick Start
guide, we'll see that first
step is to activate
the Drive API.
This is a standard first step
for any application you want
to write that uses Drive API.
To enable the use of the Drive
API, you have to go to the
API's console and enable
Drive API.
Let's do it together.
So I have the Google
API's console here.
I don't have any other projects
created, so as soon I
they go there the first thing
I see is a big, blue button
that says Create Project.
So this is what I
will click on.
When you create a project, you
have to specify what API's you
want to use.
You can enable many of them.
You can enable as many
as you need.
Each of them will have
its quota, it's going
to have some limits.
But what we need here is
just the Drive API.
So I will just scroll down
to Drive API and click on
it to enable it.
And that's it.
So now my application will be
able to use the Drive API.
We have to do some configuration
now.
So we will have to go to the API
access tab to generate our
credentials.
The Drive API uses Auth 2.0 for
authorization, so we will
need to create our credentials,
which is a client
ID and client secret
and all the other
parts you might need.
So we click on Create
Auth to Client ID.
We have to brand our
application, which is
essentially giving it a name.
I can call it Drive Realtime
Quick Start.
If you want, you
can add a logo.
You can add your homepage URL.
This is not needed for a test
application, these are
optional fields.
I can click on Next.
And then I have to specify
if I want to build a Web
application, service account
application, or an installed
application.
This is going to be a
client-side only Web
application written in
JavaScript, so Web
application is fine.
What we have to do here is to
make sure that our hostname is
authorized.
So I will click on More Options
here, and I will
remove this template here, this
sample placeholder value,
example.com/callback.
And I will just put
http://localhost with just one
L. And the same thing for
the authorize JavaScript
[? origin ?].
I'm going to use LocalHost.
Of course, if you have a Web
server where you publish your
application, you will have to
make sure that the domain for
your Web server is
listed here.
Make sure also that you don't
have HTTP, HTTPS mismatch.
So if you use HTTPS, you have
to list it here as HTTPS.
And if you need, you
can list multiple
entries, one per line.
So if I wanted I could list it
here, HTTPS LocalHost as well.
But I'm not using HTTPS,
I can remove this.
And that's it.
That's the configuration.
What I will get is
a client ID.
And the client secret and
email address I can use.
But what I need here is
just the client ID.
This is going to be a Web-only
application, a client-side
only application.
So I will only need
the client ID.
Of course, make sure that the
client secret you generate is
not shared with anyone.
So right now you can see mine,
but at the end of this talk I
will obviously revoke
this client secret.
And if you need to do it, or for
any reason you think your
client secret has leaked, to
prevent other people from
using your credentials you have
to go back to the API's
console and click Reset
Client Secret, and you
would get a new one.
With that, we're done
with step one.
Hey Claudio, can we bump
up the font just one?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: And that'll
make it better for our
viewers, thank you.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So let me--
I got asked to make
the font larger.
And so now it's easier for you
to steal my client secret.
So that was the step one, which
is activating the Drive
API and configuring
my credentials.
So step two is to
write the code.
What we're going to do here
is to have, you're going
to write two files.
One is an HTML file that uses
the other one, which is a
JavaScript file.
The JavaScript file is a
pretty generic set of
utilities you can use in this
application, but you can also
use in other applications.
So whenever you want to write a
Realtime API application, I
would recommend you talking
a look at this file.
Because this will give you some
helper functions, some
easier ways to abstract some of
the underlying complexity.
So basically, most of our logic
is going to be in the
index.html file.
Let's do this, I will copy them
and run them, and then we
will go through the code
and explain it.
So if you want to do what I'm
doing, you just go to this
page, take the HTML here,
and copy the HTML file.
I created two empty
files here.
So I can open them with
my editor and just--
oops, if didn't copy.
I can copy it for real.
Go back to the editor, paste it,
and maybe make it bigger.
So this is the HTML
file we copied.
And I can do the same thing
for the JavaScript file.
So I can go back here.
We have tabs.
So there's another file called
realtimeclientutils.js.
If you copy these files, make
sure that the file name is
correct, because the HTML file
will reference this one.
So I will do the same, and then
I will talk about this
code as soon as we
see what it does.
So there are things in this
library that we are not really
going to use, because this
is pretty generic.
I mean basically gives us more
than we need, but this is just
easier to use this library
in all your applications.
So let's do the same thing.
I will put it in the other file,
which is also empty for
the moment.
So we'll put the JavaScript
code here and Save.
So now I'm essentially done.
So I can go back to
my Web server.
I can try opening this five
from a Web server
and see what happens.
So I see that this is what
we get, and this is
exactly what we needed.
So we have these two text areas
in the two files, and
these will be synchronized.
There is just another
thing we need to do
before we can run it.
This says you must authorize,
and this is disabled.
This is because you have
to tell the app which
is your client ID.
So we have to go back to
our index.html file.
And there is a variable called
Realtime Options
that says client ID.
Insert your client ID here.
We generated our client ID
in the API's console.
So I have to go back to the
API's console, which is here,
take the client ID, copy it, and
put it here in the doc in
the HTML file instead
of the placeholder.
That's all it takes.
So now this application will
use my credentials.
So I can go back to the page,
refresh it, and now this is
working correctly.
So I see that the--
this is the first time
I've run this app.
So I have to authorize the
app and grant access to
the app to my files.
So if you want to try it,
first thing you have to
authorize it.
So you click and you
must authorize.
This is a standard Auth
2.0 dialogue.
It says that this app is
requesting permission to add
itself to Google Drive, to
view and manage files in
Google Drive that this app has
created that I opened with is
app, and know who you
are in Google.
Which means know what is
your user name and
email address, actually.
So I can say Allow Access.
This app is now authorized, and
the two text boxes will be
populated with some
initial text.
And now--
let's see if I can make
this bigger too--
now whenever I type something on
the first text box, I will
see the same content copied
onto the second one.
And also, it also works
on the other way
around which is amazing.
So if you trust me, there's
no tricks here.
This is not some local
client-side JavaScript that is
just copying and synchronizing
to text box.
This is going to our Web
server and then back.
But if you don't really trust
me, what you can do is that we
can open a separate browser.
So we have a separate
browser here.
So I open the same page,
another browser.
And you can see, I type here,
there's a small delay now, and
now two of these browsers are
synchronized in the text area.
So synchronize.
Of course, you're going
to have text areas.
I can have strings to
be synchronized.
But you can also have maps or
lists, so you can build
wherever complicated
structure you want.
This is actually just the
easiest to synchronize, a
signal string.
So this is working perfectly.
This is a very simple example.
We have a number of text boxes
to be synchronized.
You can have as many
as you want.
collaborators as you want.
Of course you can extend
this to show who is
editing what as we do.
So we provide you with some
events that tell you when a
collaborator joined and added
something, and when
they left and so on.
So you can build the
UI you want.
And it can look like ours.
So let's see how this works.
Let's go to the code now,
let's take it from here.
So let's start from
index.html.
Let's make it still
a bit bigger.
So in this HTML page the first
thing we do is of course
loading the libraries.
So we have two libraries.
One is the real time library
that comes from google.com.
And the other one is the
JavaScript file we created, so
our helper utility
function library.
And then what we say is that
when the page loads we call
this function called
a Start Realtime.
And everything else is just
the HTML of the page.
So we have a button that is
initially disabled that says
you must authorize, we have
the text areas, but the
important part is to see what
Start Realtime does.
And Start Realtime is at the
bottom of this file.
This will create a Realtime
loader, which is our helper
class, with some options
and then start it.
The options are here, where we
define the client ID, what the
ID of the button that starts the
authorization is, and what
function to call when the
model is first created.
And if we want to auto-create
a file when the application
starts for first time, what is
the title of this file that we
create, and what is the
function to call
when a files is loaded.
Let me just spend
a minute here.
So there are two functions and
there are two events that are
important here.
One is Initialize Model and the
other one is [INAUDIBLE].
Whenever you design a Realtime
API app, there's going to be
multiple events that
get fired.
Initialize Model is fired up
when the real time model is
first created.
So in our obligation a real time
model is simply a string,
but it can have a complex
structure and so on.
So let's say you have to create
your complex structure
and set up some initial values,
things like that.
And you have to do once for the
whole lifetime of the app.
That has to happen in the
Initialize Model method.
If you want something to happen
every time a user opens
that file and wants to start
using that file, then the
event that will be triggered
there is called [INAUDIBLE].
So we will do different
things here.
And let's see what
we do, actually.
So we have Initialize Model
when the app is initially
created, when the model
is initially created.
And as I said, my model, which
is the underlying structure
for my app, is just a string.
This is not a normal
string, this is a
collaborative string.
So we have methods
to create those.
And what we do here is we
instantiate a string with an
initial value that says,
Hello Realtime World.
And that's why when I started
the app, you saw
that initial value.
And then we say that
we call it text.
Not a very fancy name,
but this is what we
decided to call it.
And the other method runs
when the file is
loaded from a user.
And what we do here is binding
the controls on the page.
So the text box that you see
on the HTML, we demodel.
This is what we have to do.
Remember we have two different
text boxes in this app.
So we don't have to bind both.
We're actually binding them to
the same model strength.
But for take a sample, we are
binding it in two different
ways, because there are multiple
ways to do it.
So the first one we used
the easiest way.
So we get a reference to the
first text area using a
standard document.get
element by ID.
And we know this element is
going to be called Editor One.
And then we use a helper
function called Bind String,
which makes it super easy to
bind a string to a text area.
So this method takes two
parameters, one is the string
and the other one is
the text area.
That's all you have to do.
So this will take care of
everything for you.
If you delete something
from the text, it will
just reflect it.
If you add something, it
will just reflect it.
That's all of it.
If you don't want to use this,
or if you want to do something
different, you can instant shade
a custom event listener.
This will let you bind objects
of whatever kind you want with
UI elements of whatever kind.
So in this case, we're going to
do exactly the same thing
as the first text area,
but manually.
So first, we take the reference
to the second editor.
And then we define a function
called Update Text Area Two,
whose job is just to set the
value of this text area.
And we call this function
whenever the tax-inserted
event is triggered or when the
tax-deleted event is stricter.
So it's not super efficient.
But what we're doing here is
that whenever some text is
inserted, we replace the value
in the text box with this.
And whenever some text is
deleted we do the same thing.
And we also do that
on [INAUDIBLE].
So we set the text so that
whenever you type, you will
automatically see that the value
going from the HTML, it
goes into the model.
And that's basically it.
And once we're done with that--
so we linked the two
elements with the model.
We just enabled the UI elements
so that the user can
start playing with it.
And that's all our logic.
What is included in the Realtime
clientutils.js?
You, of course, can take
a look at that.
But what this does is taking
care of the authorization.
If you notice, we haven't done
much about authorization.
We just said, this is the idea
of the element that will
trigger the authorization.
That was it.
Because this library
will do everything.
So we list here the
scopes we need.
We take care of doing
authorization
in different modes.
So the first time you have to go
to the option Grant Access
and see the Grand
Access dialogue.
The second time you go to
the app, the app will be
automatically authorized.
And all of that is taken
care by this library.
We provide some helper functions
to split parameters
from the URI.
So if you notice in the--
it's probably small to read--
but if you notice when we
opened the app, in the URL we
had a file ID, a parameter
which included the ID of
the file on Drive.
So when I open the same page
on another browser, the
library will take the file ID
from the URL and open that
file from Drive.
So all of this is done
by the library.
And just before we wrap up,
authorize is there.
You should take a look
at that, but it
just works as it is.
And all I want to show you
is that this library also
performs some standard
Drive API calls.
So there's one called Create
Realtime File, and you might
notice that this is just
standardfiles.insert call.
So to create a Realtime file,
you create a file on Drive
with a specific MIME type.
And that's it And if you want
to get the metadata for this
file, is this just a standard
drive API call.
So you do a drive.files.get,
with the file ID.
So everything you know
about the Drive API
still applies here.
Realtime files are standard
files, standard Drive API
files with a specific
MIME type.
And that's the only
difference.
So it can do all the usual
operations in those.
And everything else here
is just boiler plate.
So this is the constructor
we called.
And it takes all the parameters
we passed, and them
[INAUDIBLE]
we're needed.
And this is where we start.
So we start with the
authorization, and that's it.
So you should probably take a
look at this in a bit more
detail, but this is out of scope
for this Quick Start.
So to summarize, I mean I spent
a lot of time explaining
it, but to go through all the
steps here, it should take you
no more than 5 to 10 minutes.
And at the end you will have
an application that behaves
like this, so that you have
multiple text boxes that are
synchronized.
And then you can just wrap up
by saying goodbye here, and
still works and it's great.
So if you want to write your
first Drive Realtime API app,
go to developers.googl
e.com/drive/realtime.
And you will find a lot of
documentation there, starting
from the Quick Start page,
which is what we
went through today.
With that, thank you so much
for joining us on Google
Developers Live.
And a sneak peak on our next
event on Tuesday, we should
have the engineer team leader
for this effort join us to
answer your questions.
So please stay tuned.
We'll give you more details
on our Google
Developers Live page.
And we'll give you a way to ask
questions directly to the
lead engineer who wrote this.
Thank you so much, see
you next time.
Thank you.